an innovative computer coding program is
part of the effort to break the cycle of
mass incarceration in the u.s. Priscilla
Chan the co-founder of the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative and wife of
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg is
helping to create opportunities for
female inmates in Oklahoma listen to
this the state is called the prison
capital of the world because it has a
higher incarceration rate than anywhere
else
Oklahoma's female incarceration rate is
more than double the national average
and only on CBS this morning Priscilla
Chan takes us inside a medium-security
prison in McLeod Oklahoma where she's
empowering female inmates with a
keyboard when you think about
rehabilitation or teaching prisoners I
think coding is really the last thing in
a lot of people's minds white coding I
was just talking to a woman in the
classroom and she's been incarcerated
for 17 years and she is ready to return
to her community and wants to contribute
and she knows that the industry in the
world has moved forward and we need to
be giving people who are incarcerated
the cutting-edge skills I was computer
completely Priscilla Chan is helping to
bring those cutting-edge skills to 18
women at Mabel Bassett Correctional
Center
it's the largest female prison in
Oklahoma with over 1200 inmates 85% of
whom are mothers use HTML through the
last mile program these women will learn
computer coding languages like HTML dot
HTML and JavaScript
how do you teach coding when there's no
internet connection at this person it's
phenomenal what they're able to achieve
but I think it just speaks to how
dedicated they are to actually learning
the skills do you really think that tech
companies will want to hire felons I
think they want to hire people who are
motivated and have the right skills and
so yes I do
she realized technology could help
unlock opportunities for others when she
and her husband Mark Zuckerburg visited
the last miles coding program at San
Quentin prison in 2015
seventy percent of individuals who are
incarcerated will come back but if you
give vocational training and goes down
to thirty percent in the last mile
program it is zero percent inside the
Oklahoma prison we met tuck Quiana
Culver dropped out of school at age 13
had her first child at 15 and was in
prison by the age of 34 in the dozen
years she has spent behind bars she's
gotten her GED and is now a college
senior majoring in business she says she
has a 3.9 GPA how much longer will you
be here two and a half more years so
you're almost there I'm almost there are
you scared when you think about what
you're going to do when you get out of
here I am I am not so terrified that I
can't think clearly I always keep in the
forefront not wanting to make the same
mistake that brought me here so or the
mistakes that got you here yeah what
happened literally wrong place wrong
time wrong people I was separated from
my husband was going through some things
and I got involved with another guy that
was not the right type of guy in drugs
drinking and I was at a place where I
shouldn't have been with him and someone
ended up dying and thank God it wasn't
by my hands but I was still there
and you were convicted of second victim
of second-degree murder what do you want
people to know about that I want people
to know that it's time to stop defining
each individual with the mistakes that
they make because if you are taught
better you do better and a mistake does
not make you a monster we are worth
Redemption and we can be redeemed we can
redeem ourselves
if talk we onna graduates she will join
the nearly 500 inmates across four
states who have completed the year-long
course to become software engineers
there are so many jobs that need to be
filled today and so I think there's an
incredible appetite for people with the
right training to do the right job one
in two individuals have a family member
or someone in their lives that is
involved in our prison system what would
you say to those who say that someone
who's been convicted of second degree
murder does not deserve a second chance
she deserves to be in prison I think we
have to be aware that all those women in
the classroom and everyone who leaves
prison has served their time it's each
one of those women is a mother as a
family member and as Bryan Stevenson
says more than the worst thing that
they've ever done really interesting to
visit that prison Oklahoma has one of
the highest incarceration rates because
they have very strict sentencing laws
there so that's why they're targeting
that particular program but it really
gave me a new understanding of some of
the women that are there I mean talk as
she is as her nickname is and she has
spent her time there trying to get
educated and be prepared for when she
gets out he's trying to redeem herself
and she said I'm terrified but not so
terrified that I can't think clearly and
I think Mozilla makes a good point you
know these people have served their time
and so once you serve your time don't
you deserve a second chance if you've
actually paid for the crime and it's
important for a sec you t'v and business
owners and tech leaders like Mark
Zuckerberg and we had bill gates on last
week talked about what they learned from
inmates right and spending and right
then who's there - yeah about that and
if you don't have skills when you go
back out in the world where you're alone
it's just you can have the the pipeline
right back is it's so clear very fast
and that's
they're spending five times more on
jails and prisons than on education just
let that numbers are out of whack oh
yeah let that sink in